c'est un beau soir thomas après une
semaine en europe a marqué par une
rencontre constructive avec made in ea
routine les choses pourraient s'avérer
on vient de le voir dans le plus
compliqué pour joe biden avec d'autres
jeunes interlocuteurs
oui le dossier nord-coréen est
finalement assez révélateur des
difficultés qui attendent au bail de
nous en avait parlé sur les difficultés
d'un dialogue avec pyongyang il faut
aussi noter que la personnalité de joe
biden est elle même au coeur des
tensions avec des mots assez durs qui
ont été échangés ces derniers mois entre
les deux dirigeants de corée du nord est
des états unis ce sera donc on peut
l'imaginer assez compliqué pour lui de
travailler sur ce dossier tout comme ça
sera compliqué concernant l'iran le
président américain avait souvent fait
part de sa volonté de rouvrir le dossier
de l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien
là il se voit là aussi opposer une
réponse ferme de la part de téhéran le
nouveau président élu
ebrahim raïssi a été interrogé lors de
sa première conférence de presse sur sa
position vis-à-vis de la maison blanche
et il a une réponse sans équivoque
écoutez si toutes les sanctions sont
levés et que les demandes de l'iran sont
satisfaites par les états unis
vous prêt à rencontrer le président
américain non j'exhorte fortement le
gouvernement américain âgé rapidement
sur ses engagements à lever toutes les
sanctions et a montré son honnêteté en
levant les sanctions
alors on le comprend bien dans la
réponse du président élu en iran le
point de blocage ce sont les sanctions
américaines des mesures prises par
washington ces dernières années à
l'encontre d'un certain nombre de pays
est encore tout récemment contre la
biélorussie par exemple et il ya un
autre pays qui est victime de ces
sanctions c'est le venezuela et la
semaine dernière le président
vénézuélien nicolás maduro a demandé
levée des sanctions américaines
refus de washington dans la foulée qui
demandent des changements majeurs de la
part du président vénézuélien
on touche donc aux limites en quelque
sorte de la diplomatie que veut mener
joe biden on sait il est adepte d'une
façon de faire plutôt à l'ancienne en
espérant pouvoir rencontrer en face à
face ses interlocuteurs mais cette
stratégie se heurte donc aux
antagonismes qui sont parfois très
profond entre les états unis les pays en
question des antagonismes que joe biden
a pu lui-même participé à alimenter
lorsqu'il était vice-président ou encore
lors de la campagne présidentielle où
l'avait tenue parfois des propos très
outrageux contre des dirigeants d'autres
pays
voilà donc le dilemme pour joe biden
aujourd'hui comment renouer un dialogue
en conservant une attitude agressive et
une politique de sanctions contre un
certain nombre de pays et en plus à
vouloir trancher de manière assez
systématique avec la diplomatie menée
par son prédécesseur donald trump
il risque de brouiller son message et de
compliquer encore davantage les dossiers
internationaux qui doit gérer
merci thomas bonnet en direct de
washington